warten auf jamaica fast drei wochen nach
der bundestagswahl und immer noch keine
sondierungsgespräche vielleicht nächste
woche dort nächste woche
warum müssen wir so lange warten unter
anderem natürlich wegen der
niedersachsen war ja über morgen
übermorgen wird gewählt da oben in der
norddeutschen tiefebene wo männer noch
cordhut tragen und frauen gummistiefel
und zwar immer meine damen und herren
ich bring uns alle mal in niedersachsen
stimmung die hülle wie sehen die lieder
sagt sturmfest und erdverwachsen herzog
gets stammen
ist es vorbei ist es soweit gut
hier sind sie jeder sachsen
und was ja was ja toll ist endlich mal
eine hoch spannende wahl am sonntag cdu
und spd liegen wieder kopf an kopf in
krisen niedersachsen wo die 90er niemals
aufhören
ja da ist es immer noch rot grün gegen
schwarz gelb und der cdu-kandidat
während althusmann warnt vor einem
kommunistischen linksbündnis das aus
hannover pjöngjang macht und und erlegt
gerne schleimspur in richtung merkel
das ist schon eine tolle kanzlerin muss
ich auch sagen ich habe sie vor kurzem
persönlich wenn mal etwas länger unter
vier augen kennenlernen dürfen eine
faszinierende frau hört sie einfach weg
zum erfolg und zu uns nach hause
eingeladen mal sehen und sie kommen doch
niemals seite nein hat sie nicht
natürlich zumal zumal der mann sich
gerade von der flüchtlingspolitik der
kanzlerin distanziert hat aber sie ist
ja zum glück nicht nach dran
gold steht dabei bernd na ja
vor ein paar monaten hatte der
apfelkuchen man hier noch zwölf
prozentpunkte vorsprung wie zum teufel
hat es der amtierende spd
ministerpräsident weil also geschafft
das aufzuholen nehme schwer an mit
seiner persönlichkeit welche
eigenschaften schreiben sie zu
freundlich liebenswürdig ein bisschen la
marché ja immer ja
blamage ich das ist das niedersächsische
adhs außerdem so lamers ist derweil gar
nicht wirklich hier im tv-duell wollte
ihn der herr althusmann angreifen wegen
vw skandal und so und dann wird's aber
böse ministerpräsident sie haben von
allem von der diesel affäre aus der
tagesschau sie haben von
kartellverfahren aus der zeitung
erfahren ich glaube sie überblicken
nicht wirklich nicht worüber sie reden
und das mache ich ihn über nicht zum
vorwurf das ist nicht leicht zu
verstehen
ich mache ihnen das gar nicht zum
vorwurf dass sie so doof sind auch für
doofe gibt's verwendung sauber gekonnt
hat denn da könnte man fast vergessen
dass sich das sich weil man den text
einer regierungserklärung vom vw
vorstand hat abnehmen lassen
die sympathie was mir allerdings gefällt
ist sein wahlspot politik ist kein
sprint
als kind hat meine mutter immer zu mir
gesagt gib dein bestes deswegen will ich
dafür kämpfen und mein bestes geben als
ministerpräsident von niedersachsen geil
oder oder guckt also über sein land und
dann joggte einfach los der spot war so
gut dass sich die werbeagentur gedacht
hat haye den kann man doch zwei mal
verkaufen
tatsächlich haben die genau das konzept
was wir gerade gesehen haben auch noch
an einen schönheitschirurgen fertigt
wirklich erst beide auf dem dach sagt
schnürsenkel zu und dann über ein acker
humpeln wahnsinn wahnsinn im nachhinein
bereue ich total dass ich mit denen auch
einen gedreht hat
ach du scheiße ich bin ja in hannover
als kind hat meine mutter immer zu mir
gesagt junge wenn du merkst dass du in
niedersachsen bist hau ab
[Musik]
man sollte mich nicht von hinten film
anschaut ja und auch nicht beim laufen
im übrigen im übrigen jetzt mal
ernsthaft hut ab niedersachsen
niedersachsen ist eines der wenigen
bundesländer in denen die afg probleme
hat kann man erklären die die afd wissen
sie arbeitet hauptsächlich mit angst
angst ist eine emotion und emotionen
japan niedersachsen das ist doch gut